it's crazy that we haven't had a
live-action Star Wars show yet but in
2019 it's finally happening it's been a
long time coming but the very first
live-action Star Wars series is on its
way he has everything you need to know
before you watch the Mandalorian in
October 2018 the Mandalorian creator Jon
Favreau posted a picture on Instagram
that evoke the classic Star Wars opening
crawl and laid out exactly what the
Mandalorian will be about a series will
focus on the travails of a lone
gunfighter in the outer reaches of the
galaxy far from the authority of the New
Republic and we'll explore the rocky
transition from the Galactic Empire to a
brand new government if that makes the
Mandalorian sound like a Western that's
not an accident at Star Wars Celebration
2019 Favreau and fellow producer Dave
Filoni confirm that the Mandalorian like
the original Star Wars is heavily
inspired by both spaghetti westerns and
Akira Kurosawa's samurai films like the
heroes in those stories the Mandalorian
is a lone fighter of questionable moral
character who flies a ship called the
Razer quest and does whatever it takes
to survive what specifics are still slim
but we know that actor Pedro Pascal will
star as a title character who like Star
Wars fun favourite Boba Fett's wears a
suit of iconic Mandalorian armor still
according to reports Pascal isn't
modelling his performance off Boba
Fett's but rather on Clint Eastwood's
classic character the man with no name
Pascal previously headlined the Netflix
series narcos but you probably know him
best as Oberyn Martell the dude who had
his head crushed by the mountain on Game
of Thrones
joining Pascal will be cold weathers
best known for playing Apollo Creed in
the rocky films weathers will play grief
the head of a loose coalition of bounty
hunters who sends the Mandalorian on a
special mission you take this home throw
it in a pot add some broth a potato did
you get us to God yeah not that kind of
mission that mission we'll bring him in
contact with a program by a crime lord
to play by acclaim director Verner
Hertzog as well as Cora dune a former
rebel shock trooper played by MMA legend
Gina Carano other confirmed cast members
include Breaking Bad Giancarlo Esposito
as a Thai fighter pilots as well as
Academy Award nominee Nick Nolte
supernaturals Emily swallow
American Gods Oh meetup table a and
comedian bill burr that's a lot of star
power clearly Disney isn't messing over
if series producer Jon Favreau's name
rings a bell there's a pretty good
reason for that
as he's quietly become one of Disney's
biggest power players
Favreau first made his name back in the
day by directing the hit swingers and
elf but he rose to a whole new level in
2008 as a director of Ironman the movie
that single-handedly launched the Marvel
Cinematic Universe revitalizing Robert
Downey jr. as career and made Tony Stark
a household name plus he co-starred in
it too was Tony's assistant happy Hogan
since then he directed Iron Man 2 and
produced The Avengers before becoming
Disney's go-to director for live-action
adaptations including the Jungle Book
and The Lion King and he's also a
bonafide Star Wars geek not only did he
voiced the character Bo Durant and solo
he also helped flesh out the law of the
Mandalorians as a villainous Pre Vizsla
in the animated series the Clone Wars
and speaking of that if you aren't a
hardcore Star Wars historian you might
not even know what the name Mandalorian
means don't worry though we have you
covered in the original Star Wars
trilogy the bounty hunter Boba Fett or a
suit of Mandalorian armor which we
learned in the prequel trilogy was
handed down from his father Jango Fett
presumably after a thorough cleaning but
there's much more to it than that in the
Clone Wars it was revealed that Jango
Fett wasn't even from Mandalore
he was just wearing someone else's armor
instead the planet Mandalore has a long
and complex history ravaged by centuries
of war including an ancient conflict
with the Jedi Mandalore was again
plunged into civil war during the Clone
Wars Darth Maul use this as an
opportunity to seize power conquering
the planet and using it as a base of
operations for his criminal syndicate
the shadow collective so yeah moles
brief solo cameo wasn't quite as random
as it seems well except for the fact
that he got chopped in half once but you
know happens happens to the best of us
it's fitting that the history of the
Mandalorians was explored in a cartoon
because Boba Fett himself first appeared
in an animated segment of the Star Wars
Holiday Special
while the rest of the film is reviled
animated short the faithful Wookiee is
worth a watch it was produced by Nelvana
Studios whose animates us look to
westerns and storyboarding the shorts
meaning the Mandalorian
spaghetti-western roots have been
begged into the show's DNA right from
the very start as revealed at the solo
premiere the Mandalorian will take place
a few years after The Return of the Jedi
and a couple of decades before the force
awakens at this point the Rebel Alliance
has transformed into the New Republic
while the former Imperials had
eventually formed the first order are
still looking their wounds in the
galaxy's Unknown Regions Leia Organa is
busy serving in the Galactic Senate her
husband han Solo splits his time between
taking care of their kid Ben ie the
future kylo Ren racing spaceships
running his own shipping company and
teaming up with his buddy Lando for the
occasional New Republic mission don't
expect to see any of them in the
Mandalorian however the new Disney
television show takes place far from the
New Republic's capital and will likely
feature mostly new characters still the
Mandalorian is set to feature at least
one classic Star Wars foe ig-88 a bounty
hunting droid who appeared in The Empire
Strikes Back will be played in the
Mandalorian by Taika Waititi who stole
the show was cog in thor ragnarok amen
I'm cool this is me we're gonna jump on
their spaceship and get out of here want
to come the Mandalorians will also be
full of familiar sights and sounds
including Jawa sandcrawler x' lizard
like dewbacks Return of the Jedi style
speeder bikes and one droid that classic
Star Wars fan to recognize immediately
the Mandalorians main cast might be
brand new but don't worry you're still
going to feel right at home
showrunner Jon Favreau clearly has the
chops to get it done but he won't be
making them under Lorien alone instead
he and executive producer Kathleen
Kennedy have rounded up a stable of
behind-the-scenes talents that's just as
impressive as a roster of stars they've
lined up in front of the camera perhaps
most importantly two Star Wars fans of
the involvement of producer Dave Filoni
the Loney is one of the figures most
responsible for modern Star Wars canon
beyond directing the Clone Wars feature
film he co-created the animated series
rebels and resistance he is also
responsible for creating the fan
favorite Jedi apprentice ahsoka tano
plus he provided the voice of the
scene-stealing droid chopper polonius
involvement will make sure that the
series is completely in tune with Star
Wars law and felonious just one of
several big names who will be directing
episodes of the Mandalorian joining him
behind the camera restore Ragnarok
director Taika Waititi who as we
previously mentioned is also playing
ig-88 as
as actress Bryce Dallas Howard Howard is
best known for starring in films like
Jurassic world but she has begun
shifting a direction to directing just
like a father
solo director Ron Howard once did
further down the list you'll find
reckfarmer ye hwa director of the
criminally underrated dope as well as
Debra Chao a television veteran who's
worked on shows like rain Jessica Jones
mr. robots better call Saul and the man
in the high castle you know just some of
the best dramas currently on television
honestly it's hard to imagine a better
lineup but then again it's not every day
you get to contribute to a cultural
institution we wouldn't be surprised to
the mandalorian as talent lined up
around the block just waiting for a shot
at a galaxy far far away while the
Mandalorian would be a hit on almost any
channel you're not going to be able to
watch it via regular cable the show will
air exclusively on Disney Plus Disney's
streaming service is going to be the new
home for well almost everything a series
launches on November 12 2019 and the
mandalorian pilot will be available on
day one a subscription will cost $6.99 a
month or $70 have you subscribed for a
full year if you're a star Wars fan
you're probably going to want to
subscribe in addition to the mandalorian
Disney Plus will host all of the Star
Wars movies a new season of animated
series the Clone Wars and behind the
scenes documentaries and reportedly
that's just the beginning
this new plus will also be crammed full
of Marvel contents including all of the
MCU movies a Scarlet Witch Vision
team-up called wonder vision a Loki solo
series a falcon and Winter Soldier show
and the animated what-if adaptation
every single one of Disney's animated
films even those initially relegated to
the vault will be on Disney Plus as will
original Disney programming like high
school musical the series a rumored
Muppets revival and more throw in all 30
seasons of The Simpsons and more from
Disney's new Fox library and you're
going to get a heck of a lot of content
for your money
watch out Netflix the mandalorian is
coming to the Disney family and soon
appearing a Disney Plus I for one salute
our new corporate overlords and isn't
coming alone Disney has announced that
there will be a second live-action Star
Wars series coming to the Disney Plus
streaming service it just might not be
the one you think fans of course have
been waiting for over a decade to see
episodes of the long rumored live-action
Star Wars series Star Wars
the world first announced by George
Lucas way back in 2005 Star Wars and the
world was reportedly set between the
prequel and original trilogy's focusing
on the criminal underbelly on the
imperial capital planet of Khorasan
Lucasfilm reportedly developed over 50
completed scripts for the series but
there was one big problem the show was
too expensive to make clocking in at a
whopping 20 million dollars per episode
so Lucas production on hiatus until
technology advanced enough to make
filming cheaper before that happened
though he sold Star Wars to Disney in
2013 Disney announced that they were
reading star wars underworld and nothing
has ever been done with her since so
when the company announced the two
live-action series fans hoped the time
would finally come but well not quite
instead the second live-action series
will star Diego Luna as casseon and/or
one of the lead characters from the hit
film rogue one of Star Wars story the
show is described as a prequel series
set between the original and the prequel
trilogy focusing on quote at the
formative years of the rebellion still
there's some hope that star wars
underworld will eventually see the light
of day because the Mandalorian is
reportedly going to Costas need 10
million dollars per episode to make
certainly that 20 million dollar per
episode price tag for Star Wars
underworld doesn't seem so impossible
after all check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more loop of
videos about star wars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]